[Music]
my work is called the draw of everyday
designs
i somehow had this idea of bringing back
this
element of nostalgia you know
in primary school even secondary school
sometimes you have you have a stem right
it says good job
that's where i came up with this design
awards
[Music]
trophies are essentially the same thing
right it's giving you that seal of
approval
that stem of approval so i put the power
back into the people right to really
judge the designs for themselves
[Music]
it is also part of my intention are to
create a physical fun experience for
them to engage in but i think with these
i'm using
very familiar icons
familiar objects even within the curated
objects within the card
so i feel that it's very easily
understandable for the everyday people
and that's also one of my objectives
to resonate with people
the viewers coming to this exhibition
[Music]
design superposition essentially means
that there's many meanings to
to to design
i think what i did was
was to take a slice of what
the brief means i think part of the
brief was really about how design
is
neither
available nor useless until you observe
until you measure it
and i carried through and and really
took that slice out and created this
exhibit
as you judge the designs right there's
many different takes on what design is
on what the value of design can be
do you have the authority to judge
designs on your own there's no right or
wrong and i'm here communicating through
a series of artifacts and
a mini activity
[Music]
to me the result is not this
nice looking trophies or like this
beautifully designed card but it's about
the the end conversations that people
can have
going through this
[Music]
you